[Music]
welcome everyone to this session on
camera X my name is Veneto and I'm the
product manager on the Android camera
platform team today we'll show you how
to minimize the camera development time
with a consistent and easy to use camera
API we'll have some code walkthroughs a
lot of fun demos and we'll end by
showing how you can elevate your in-app
experiences now many of you know this
camera development is hard why is that
within your apps you need to account for
various OSS second you have to provide a
consistent experience across a range of
devices from entry level to flagships
and finally the camera api's are very
powerful but difficult to master
so we're excited to give you this first
glimpse into camera X this last support
library is launching as part of jetpack
in alpha we develop completely in the
open part of Android open source project
we update multiple times a year so let's
learn more so camera X is backwards
compatible to Android L this works with
90% of devices in the market today so
when your target SDK is API 21 or higher
you'll be able to use camera X under the
hood camera X uses the public camera to
api's now we know what you're thinking
what about the old deprecated camera one
API so we provide the same consistency
as camera 1 via the camera 2 legacy
layer we've tested identified and fixed
a number of issues across these older
devices
so how do we achieve this consistent
behavior last summer I was in China at
the Android GDD event and was shocked to
learn that several developers are
running manual testing across hundreds
of devices so we understand your pain
and felt that the best way is to invest
in an automated camera test lab this
test lab has devices from Android L all
the way through Q has devices from
various manufacturers and it runs 24
hours a day seven days a week by
providing an automated testing
experience were able to guarantee a high
quality camera performance across all
your apps we've tested hundreds of
devices across all OS layers to date and
we do basic testing like orientation
rotation taking a picture one of this
test suite is the latency test suite and
we're open sourcing that test suite with
this test you'll be able to start
benchmarking your camera start/stop
latencies your latency is for a photo
capture this is a very powerful tool
that we've used very recently with a lot
of the top Android applications here's
just a list of example issues that we've
tackled with camera X and we solve that
on your behalf for example the front and
back camera crashes optimizing camera
closures or just making sure that the
flash works now this is our season
premiere of camera X there lots and lots
of devices out there so we really hope
that you try out this season you try out
this alpha version give us your feedback
and then as we improve it'll just keep
getting better finally I want to talk
about how camera X is incredibly easy to
use the current camera to API gives you
very fine-grained control over the all
the sensors what we've done is
abstracted away the hard bits and
provide a use case based API that simply
lets you get a display up on screen
gives you high-quality frames so you can
do amazing analysis and simply take a
picture or a video finally we bind all
these use cases to the apps activity
lifecycle making sure that camera X is
life cycle aware and you don't have to
start and stop the camera separately
anymore awesome so here's the typical
walkthrough the camera app architecture
today your camera app might be talking
to the public camera2 api and under the
hood it's talking to the device hal or
the hardware abstraction layer in this
case all the device specific courts have
to be accounted for within your
application now let's imagine you using
camera X in this case camera X hides all
that from you we just give you
consistent reliable performance now
there are a lot of advanced use cases
and for that we have an experimental
version where you can interoperate
between camera 2 and camera X so let me
welcome Trevor up here on stage we're
going to do a demo on the camera 360 app
now camera 360 is based in China they
have hundreds of millions of installs
across Android and only on this stage
you'll see a demo on a 2016 Samsung j7
this device is running Android 6
marshmallow and under the hood camera X
is talking to the camera to legacy layer
he's able to change all the effects all
this is done using camera X now camera
360 is usually is using all the three
use cases preview image analysis and
image capture they're using image
analysis or track Trevor's face and draw
the effects around it and whenever
Trevor is happy with the picture he
likes he take he clicks the button and
takes a picture
[Music]
it's so easy and fun I want to get in on
the next picture Thank You Trevor
so camera 360 had a number of benefits
with camera acts they were able to
reduce their device-specific testing and
saw a 75% reduction in lines of code
compared to camera two this is in
addition to making the code easier to
read and a smaller apk size so let's
summarize camera X is backwards
compatible to Android L working on 90%
of devices today we provide a consistent
experience across devices and we test
using the automated camera X test lab
and the API is incredibly easy to use
with a use case base approach so up next
is James Fung will deep dive into this
API thank you
thanks for neat my name is James I'm a
software engineer on the camera X team
we talked briefly about use cases so
these were the preview image analysis
and image capture when we sat down to
design camera rack so we realized we had
to balance a few design constraints we
want to make an API that's simple to use
we want to create an abstraction level
that lets us hide device specific issues
we also want to make sure that the API
is flexible enough so that you can
create fully featured applications so
how did we think about this how did we
go about this we figured about creating
a programming model where we really are
capturing the intent of the developer
but also providing the right amount of
flexibility so really we have an API and
we'll walk through some examples where
we're really asking three things from
the application first what's the
intended usage which of the use cases
one are multiple do you want to use
preview image analysis and image capture
secondly or should the output go when
you get the frames how does that hook up
to your application so that you can
write the code that you need to do and
finally when should the camera start
when should the camera stop so I'm gonna
walk through some code now and these
examples of being caught Lin say you
have a device at your workstation and
you're starting to use a camera for the
first time one of the things you might
want to do is start up that camera and
see those live frames directly on screen
we call that preview let's take a look
at what the code looks like for that we
start by configuring a preview so here I
built a preview config using a builder
I'm showing it here in his default
configuration the default configuration
is actually fairly powerful what this is
going to do is on that particular device
it's going to understand the available
resolutions it's also going to
understand the resolution of the display
and it's going to try and make a
reasonable decision based on that for
you
it will default also to the back camera
and making sure that the default
configuration ones well is an example of
something that we're able to test in our
lab now at this point you could set
additional options if you needed them
we'll show some examples coming up now
that we have configured the preview we
can actually create a preview use case
simply by handing it the config and
we'll see if these use cases actually
have API specific methods the preview
provides a method to set a listener
what's going to happen now is when the
preview becomes active it's going to
output a preview output the current
version outputs within the preview
output a surface texture that's
configured and ready you can use a
surface texture to attach to a texture
view or use this with a GL renderer
future versions may interact with
surface view or accept the surface
texture from the application now with
this code camera X is configured we just
need to be able to turn it on and turn
it off so the third step when should the
camera start when should the camera stop
we do this by binding the previous case
to an activity lifecycle
now what this means is when the activity
starts the PP is going to start and the
camera is going to start to stream when
the activity stops the preview is going
to stop the camera is going to shut down
other life cycles can also be used for
example a fragment life cycle could be
used here instead and in this way we're
able to hide the complexity of start and
stop in particular shutting down things
in the right order can be kind of tricky
so here you see all three steps being
done together now a real camera
application will have additional code
there would need to be code for setting
up permission attaching to views
and managing the surface texture but we
do show here is actually sufficient to
get the camera system set up we've
hidden many of the details of camera -
for example opening the camera creating
the session preparing the correct
surfaces selecting the resolutions and
the careful shutdown that you sometimes
have to do to make sure that everything
works just right I'll pause here just
for a second so you can look at slide
so let's say you have that first
previous dreaming now maybe the next
thing you want to do is be able to
access that camera data so you can do
some analysis or image processing on it
so for this we have something called
image analysis which provides easy
access to the buffers from the camera so
that you can perform your own analysis
what does it look like it really follows
the same steps that we showed with the
preview first we're gonna go ahead and
create a config here I'm gonna show what
it looks like the set an option on a
config in this case we're gonna request
a resolution now let's say your
processing requires some minimum
resolution for it to succeed this is
where you can specify that what camera X
then is going to do is it's gonna
balance the requests from your
application with the device capability
so it's going to look at your target
resolution request from image analysis
it's also going to understand if you
have a preview running the requirements
there and it's gonna balance all that by
looking also at what the device is
capable of so if you're able to get the
target resolution you'll get it if not
we'll try an X higher resolution so that
you can get some guaranteed minimum
failing that we will fall back to a 640
by 480 resolution which is guaranteed
across all devices the key thing here
being that camera X is doing everything
it can to make sure on that particular
device it's setting up a session that
will run for you once we have the config
again we can go ahead create the use
case object itself
step two what do we do with the output
now in the case of image analysis it
lets your applications set an analyzer
the analyzer is provided an image proxy
this is a camera X abstraction but
basically is wrapping an Android media
image class so you have the same access
to the same data there you'll notice we
also have a rotation parameter that's
set here we understand rotation can be
really important for image analysis now
camera X is not going to rotate the data
internally because we know if you're
going to do an analysis pass maybe
you're doing a per pixel pass already
and it might be more efficient for you
to do the rotation in place if you
wanted rather what we mean by rotation
here is we're going to make it easy for
your application to understand which way
is up in that image buffer that you've
received no-english ways up can be
important for example if you're doing a
face detection perhaps your face
detection model requires knowledge of
which way is up for it to work correctly
and it's inside the analyzer then that
you have all this information you have
the image available to you and you can
actually insert the code that you need
to get your job done
finally step three when to start and
stop here again we bind to a life cycle
so this is an example now of binding
both in image analysis and the preview
at the same time now what this means is
when the activity becomes active both
image analysis and preview will be
running at the same time and ready so
here we have again all three of the
steps together for the image analysis
what's going to happen now is when the
camera system sets up that preview is
going to come up but also your analyzer
function is going to start to receive
images at the camera frame rate and your
analysis is going to start running I'm
really proud to say that we partnered
with lens and camera X is being used
inside lens and Google go lens and
Google go is a version of lens intended
to target low-end devices that helps
users understand text some of the
benefits they expressed to us was that
it allowed them to focus on their core
competency understanding the text and
creating a really great user experience
they were able to spend less time
worried about the camera stack they were
happy that they found that camera acts
just worked on a diversity of low-end
devices lens and Google go also has a
tight apk budget size with one of our
early builds they were able to integrate
the camera stack into their application
for less than 30 kilobytes
image capture image capture allows you
to take a high-quality picture with the
camera in sight image capture we do
things like implement focus control
handle auto exposure and handle auto
white balance sometimes called 3a
additionally within image capture we're
able to optimize capture requests on a
per device basis if necessary let's take
a look at how that looks it's gonna
follow the same pattern as our previous
use cases so first we create a config
now we know getting rotation on devices
can be tricky getting portrait mode and
landscape mode just right on a variety
of devices is hard what we've done here
is reduce the problem to having the
application specify its current display
rotation what's going to happen now is
internally inside camera X we're going
to look at the rest of the transforms on
the device and make sure that our output
is doing the right thing for your
application for example in the case of
image capture we're going to understand
instead of transforms and we're going to
make sure that the X is made it did it
is set correctly then we go ahead and
create the actual image capture use case
itself then we bind to the life cycle as
before now here's an example of binding
all the three use cases together preview
image analysis and now image capture
again here's the code to set up the
image capture and so now when the
activity starts the preview is going to
come on screen if you have any analysis
it'll be running and your application is
ready to take a picture but what about
step two what about attaching that
output it's another example of a use
case specific method so for taking a
picture it might be pretty common that
the user would tap on screen that would
have activated button click and perhaps
that button click would call into some
function let's say on
so when user clicks a button now this
can invoke a function and within that
function you can simply call image
capture take picture here I show first
preparing a file and this will be the
destination of the image and then simply
calling the image capture take picture
function with that take picture function
you can then specify the target
destination the file itself you can also
specify what to do after the image is
captured by specifying a listener you
can specify what to do on error or what
to do after damage has been saved
really happy that we've been able to
demo or will you've been able to partner
with a company called snow and we'll be
able to demo that today so snow is an
application they're based in Korea and
have a really large multi-million user
install base so Trevor is going to help
us demo this again so snow is a really
fun app for taking selfies and we're
gonna show this demo this is running on
an a samsung s ten plus and we're
showing all the different use cases we
talked about we're showing preview to
get the image on screen we're showing
image analysis to detect the face and
then also render an overlay and then the
whole gang is going to come up and
finally when we're ready let's see if we
can kind of get a picture that we like
with all the foxes when we're ready we
can even go ahead and use the image
capture and that'll take a photo these
guys
so this is a great example with what we
have today of using all these three use
cases together to create a fully
featured application for taking fun
selfies working with snow they express
on the benefits of camera acts to us
they found it was easy to use they
appreciated that we managed the camera
lifecycle they also appreciated that we
handled camera threatening internally to
camera X without the need for them to
have that in their application so in
summary we've talked about the use cases
preview image analysis image capture we
talked about a programming model built
around three steps and with just preview
and image analysis we talked about how
that can make things for easier for
example for ml hooking up to ml I show
an example using lens and Google go and
finally we've shown that what we have
today is actually flexible enough to
create a fully featured camera based
application now what I've shown today is
a starting point this is a glimpse into
the direction we're taking with camera
API what is available today and I'm
really happy to have you guys try it out
thanks
[Applause]
thanks James so with one more thing to
talk about there are many new camera
capabilities that are typically part of
the native camera app for example
portrait night HDR and beauty we've
heard from many of you wanting access to
these device specific capabilities and
we're excited to share the camera X
extensions enables just that we've
partnered with some of the top
manufacturers across the world from
samsung huawei LG and Motorola and
you'll start seeing devices supporting
these extensions this summer with Huawei
you'll be able to see the HDR and
portrait effects on four existing device
models that we'll be upgrading this
summer and best of all it's two lines of
code if a device doesn't support any
specific functionality then the boolean
returns as false and it's a no op
there's no manufacturer specific coding
required on your part camera x handles
all of that for you
so we're excited to show you a demo on
the Samsung s 10 plus so I'll welcome
Franklin back up on stage so this app
that Franklin's running is the camera X
sample app what Franklin is going to do
is take two images a picture with the
normal mode and a picture with the HDR
mode and let's compare the two images so
in the HDR image you'll see that the you
know the light that's coming out of the
glass door is actually better the table
or the podium here is quite dark in the
normal picture but it's more lighted up
in the HDR picture so all of these
functionalities can be added very simply
within your application Thank You
Franklin
so here's a picture comparison of images
taken using camera X on the Left you'll
see HDR off and on the right you'll see
HDR on and we have one more Samsung will
be the first manufacturer to bring night
mode images to developers on the Left
you'll see an image in low-light
conditions and it's grainy but on the
right with the night mode enabled that
image is sharp the colors are more vivid
and imagine the experiences that you can
bring to your users when you enable
these extensions so we have one more
demo this demo is the app you can
perfect it's a camera first application
based in Taiwan with hundreds of
millions of installs this demo is on the
hallway may 20 pro and it's running the
camera X extensions both in the
viewfinder and in image capture so let's
jump to the phone mode so it's showing
the desktop
there you go
perfect so in the app all it's using is
two lines of code for camera X to enable
the extensions and you'll see that
behind me the effect is actually blurred
out so let's try a glam shot cool so
underneath it's using all the device
specific capabilities there's no
computational photography that you can
have to do so this type of behavior can
be enabled in all your applications
thank you
so here are some of the benefits that
you can express to us when using camera
X to get access to a lot of new features
that are the same as the native camera
app and the best of all it's still
reduces the lines of code it's seventy
percent fewer lines of code compared to
camera to all of this in top of getting
a consistent experience across devices
and an easy-to-use API so let's recap
what we've talked about in this session
today camera X is backwards compatible
to Android L working with 90% of devices
on market provides a consistent behavior
across a number of devices and we do a
lot of the testing for you with an
automated camera X test lab the API is
easy to use and lifecycle aware and
finally with the new extensions
capabilities you'll be able to try a lot
of new effects on newer devices we
sincerely hope that this is the API and
the changes that you're looking for and
we really value and look forward to your
feedback I want to thank some of the
early developers that are partnered with
us on camera X and they've provided us a
lot of guidance and constructive
feedback so you can download camera X
today you can add it into your
application just like other jetpack
libraries and please share your feedback
with us either by joining the Google
group or you tagging us on Stack
Overflow
you can meet us in the sandbox you'll be
able to see some of the live demos that
we did also in the sandbox or you can
reach us in office hours tomorrow so
thank you very much for attending
[Music]
you